the chicky science show clips
um so one thing that i'm interested in
um as well from a kind of biochemical
perspective is potentially combining
different interventions together and so
i know in one of the earlier akg studies
they did it in worms and they found that
akg alone extended their lifespan but if
the worms were dietary restricted they
didn't see that or they didn't see as
much of a benefit and so i wondered what
your thoughts are on not necessarily
just akg but actually combining
different interventions together and
whether or not they could be synergistic
or potentially detrimental
i i think the i'm positive about this
approach in the long run but right now
i don't think we can predict what's
going to happen we've tested a large
number of combinations of mice
and we do find we've never found
anything that's toxic but we do find
things that cancel each other out and
some things don't seem to interact at
all other things are additive and i
honestly can't predict what's gonna
what's gonna happen when we start the
experiment so
you know there are a lot of hackers out
there that are taking 15 different
things and and their pills now
they're coming out that give you 12
different things to slow aging
i honestly don't know what happens when
you take 12 different things and i i
think that that's where we want to get
to maybe not 12 but we want to get to
multiple interventions to maximize the
effect but i don't think we really know
how to do that yet and
the other thing i'll say is if if you
get a pill that has 12 things in it and
it's this big
ask yourself how much of each one could
it possibly have
because uh
you know the akg bills with the vitamin
a are this big and they're we'd like to
make them smaller but we have to make
them that big to get the product in
now if you imagine 12 things so i think
that the anti-aging
you know market is still full of a lot
of things that
that probably don't work uh having said
that there are some things that are very
intriguing the akg the nad precursors
and some of the other stuff and
i think that it's fine for people to go
ahead and start trying things i
encourage them to to be educate
themselves and try things but you know
we have to really validate this and
figure out what's working in the long
run
you